so yesterday CNN held back-to-back
climate change town halls with a number
of the twenty20 Democratic candidates
and it just went on for hours and hours
and I'd sort of dipped in and out of it
during a twitch livestream that I did
last night it was relatively uneventful
but there were some interesting things
that happened the first one I want to
mention a one notable trend is that it
again wasn't great for Joe Biden and I
don't want to make it seem like I'm
piling on Biden because there were also
other candidates who have no shot who
didn't do well like Amy Klobuchar I
don't think did very well during this
thing Kamala Harris I don't think did
well although she is in fourth place and
I guess you can say she still has a shot
I the the point is Biden is leading in
the polls and he really didn't have a
good climate change Town Hall this was
seven hours of back-to-back-to-back Town
Hall's with candidates the idea was a
good one which is let's go in-depth on
the issue of climate with each candidate
this is a really important issue and we
want to know who can go deep on these
topics great Kamala Harris had some
weird moments she had one about plastic
and paper straws that was sort of odd
Andrew yang was asked about quantifying
carbon dioxide reduction that we can get
from geoengineering which he has pushed
and talked about he wasn't able to
answer that okay some people said it was
Istanbul he should have been prepared
Biden really didn't do well he was again
not answering questions clearly and
there was this moment when what was
clearly a planned attack question was
put to Joe Biden take a look have to ask
how can we trust you to hold these
corporations and executives accountable
for their crimes against humanity when
we know that tomorrow you are holding
high-dollar fundraiser hosted by Andrew
Goldman a fossil fuel executive and the
fact of the matter is that what we talk
about is what are we going to do about
this corporation what have we done and a
law everywhere along the way
for example I've argued and we've been
pushed for us suing those executives who
are engaged in pollution those companies
who are engaged in flusha
so Biden says wait wait wait Andrew
Goldman isn't a fuss
fuel executive and the relevance to this
entire conversation is that Joe Biden
pledged not to take campaign funds from
fossil fuel executives and if indeed he
is involved with Andrew Goldman fossil
fuel executive and money is being raised
and money is being donated that would
appear to be a violation of Joe Biden's
pledge now
it was later sort of clarified weirdly
by Anderson Cooper not by Joe Biden that
Andrew Goldman is not a fossil fuel
executive but he is a fossil fuel
investor so technically Joe Biden's
pledge remains in force
I guess because he is not taking the
money from executives but rather from
investors it's one of these situations
though where you really need to
understand the dynamics of what took
place first of all this was by every
indication one of these planned attacks
on Biden but it was effective and the
clarification came later the
clarification came from Anderson Cooper
rather than from Biden himself
substantively I don't think that
anything shocking was revealed at this
Town Hall about Biden or anyone else but
the longer format for each candidate
does let us get more of a sense of how
deep their knowledge --is the knowledge
in climate from lots of the candidates
is quite frankly not very deep and I
think that that should alarm all of us
given that it is such a major
humanitarian crisis and an issue of
national security and an issue of
geopolitics and it's disappointing now
I'm not saying Trump has any better idea
Trump writes the entire thing off as a
hoax created by the Chinese that's a
disaster as well at least the people on
yesterday's stages acknowledged the
problem that there is but this was not a
good moment for Joe Biden then just bad
luck and timing by Biden this act I
actually feel bad about this he burst a
blood vessel in his eye during the event
which was noticeable on television that
led to the obviously predictable slew of
allegations that Joe Biden is sick
sort of like the Hillary Parkinson's
type stuff that's all completely to be
expected and there are sort of two
perspectives on this anti Biden stuff
that are growing on the left there are
those who are against Biden because he's
simply a centrist people are more
progressive and they say I want
someone more progressive and biden's
sort of a corporate center-left Democrat
there are others who oppose Joe Biden
because they believe that Joe Biden is
not electable in other words that he
could not beat Donald Trump in the
general election now the politics part I
understand Biden is not nearly the most
progressive candidate in fact he's one
of the most centrist candidates that is
simply a reality the Biden can't beat
Trump stuff requires a little bit of
fortune-telling and seeing into the
future but if you look at the
hypothetical polling matchups right now
against Trump Biden is routinely doing
the best period and the reason why is
not as progressivism clearly or is lack
thereof it's a demographic issue more
than anything else
older people vote much more than younger
people and they vote much more reliably
than younger people and when you look at
the demographics of who is supporting
Joe Biden you understand that any likely
voter model that accounts for how likely
people are to vote does help Joe Biden
and Joe Biden in the hypothetical
matchups does the best against Donald
Trump than anybody else now Bernie's not
far behind Warren is not far behind
Bernie but it's important to understand
where those numbers come from and I know
that every time we talk about this I get
emails from people saying David you are
drastically under estimating that young
people this time around are going to be
the difference-maker I hope that's the
case I hope that that's the case but
every election cycle we hear that and
rarely does it actually become a reality
older people are the reliable voters and
the younger people simply are not I hope
it is different but understand why a
likely voter model would not assume that
because we talk about it every election
half a cycle and it basically doesn't
end up happening now let's talk more
broadly about one of the macro issues
that is a huge red herring in the
discussions of climate